bonjour merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui alors je les dis hein vous
travaillez aujourd'hui en france vos
parents ont sont encore en afghanistan
avec vos frères et soeurs qu'elles font
les dernières nouvelles que vous avez de
votre famille
bonjour monsieur on fait de l'appeler
hier soir avec ma mère je parlais avec
ma mère a toujours pleurer cela dit on
est d'angers italie talibans y sont me
suis beaucoup de personnes ont fêté hier
soir ils ont mis tué quatre personnes
qui les les choses on travaille donc
gouvernement fait mais mon père elle
travaille donc gouvernement pourrait lui
c'est très drôle c'est très très de
danger ouvrez votre famille aujourd'hui
est ce que votre famille se cache là
reste restent cloîtrés à la maison
bah on fait mon père et les cacher ma
mère est là dit elle a diminué chez ma
cousine ont fait de mon père et les
cachets pouvait très bien qu est-ce que
ses passions la guérison qu'est ce que
c'est qu'est ce qui se passe en
afghanistan elles ont nui tuer beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes ils ont nui tuer
tout le monde on fait c'est un truc de
fou je sais pas comment c'est pas
logique comme son fait et c'est un truc
de ouf
je peux pas je peux pas laisser ma
famille quand on fait des zones où elles
sont ils sont danger et son réseau même
les autres les [ __ ] au boulot me
suis beaucoup les ont fait
j'avais fini ma mairie reçoit les
talibans avaient promis une amnistie
générale pour tous et personne pour tous
ces fonctionnaires qui avaient travaillé
avec le gouvernement vous nous dites que
votre père a travaillé avec le
gouvernement vous ne croyez pas à la
promesse des talibans d'épargné ce qui
aurait travaillé avec le gouvernement
avant
on fait de mon père était huet
travailler avec l'autre et présidente en
afghanistan les gars de coursives des
présidente en afghanistan vous va être
très bien comme anglo messieurs
présidente il est parti elle est là
voulaient beaucoup d'argent les partis
comme ça elle a laissé le jeu comme ça
en fait je croyais pas que c'est sa
chance avec elle calme et je pense pas
mais j'aimais j'espère que ça va être
bouger un pouce avait été ça va être
calme et impôts mais je pense pas
aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous avez été contacté
par les autorités françaises au sujet
d'un retour d'une arrivée en tout cas
sur le sol français de votre famille
bon on fait des
jeux pas contacté avec kaka ce décès
pour 100 fait ça fait une semaine et
j'ai passé à à la radio il s'appelle
fort france bleu nord j'ai la passe et
j'ai expliqué tout ça bah je le dis mon
père et il travaille donc gouvernement
et les gardes et les garde-côtes chef le
monsieur présidente h à gagny bages et
expliquer tout ça mais je parie sur
nouvelle je parte novell rien du tout
est ce que vous envisagez
un moyen un autre moyen de les faire
venir en france
bon en fait ce geste et je voudrais une
truc c'est pas grand'chose journée un
truc à messieurs mac rhône messieurs
président de macs rhône qu'il faut
ramener ma femme il faut format et dès
que je ramène ma famille en france parce
que vraiment vraiment ils sont en train
de jauger
merci beaucoup ahmad zaki cad en tout
cas vous n'êtes pas le fun et votre
appel a sûrement étaient entendus merci
beaucoup je l ai bien cru qu'on fait
deux jours les jeux sont faits d'où des
talibans ils sont il est vrai et son
neveu il courait pour mon père et l'a
dit
pourquoi vous travail d'un gouvernement
si je trouvais un jour je te mets tu es
directement c'est pour ça mon père et
les cacher mon mes parents ils sont tous
cachés ils ont déménagé et sont
déménagés partout en fait mais si call
calme atone faut m'aider s'il vous plaît
merci à vous merci merci beaucoup ahmad
zaki cas d'avoir d'avoir encore une fois
été avec merci pour votre votre
témoignage